hey everybody alyssay here filling in
for Ryan right as you all know I really
freakin like transformers it's my thing
I love it I follow it I watched it since
I was little it's amazing I think
Michael Bay is doing a really good job
with most of the things but today we're
going to watch the faith TV spot or age
of extinction so here we go
you come to destroy us but a greater
threat isn't coming
I love Optimus Prime he's the best that
was good I liked it it was a little
short I mean for a 30-second trailer
it's not bad I think they could have
given us a little more it was just kind
of snippety if that makes any sense no
I'm just excited yeah dinosaurs I don't
know I still I still cannot see Marky
Mark as a dad especially to that chick I
just I can't you can't put it together I
don't know what do you guys think next
TV spot Triceratops I didn't even know
there was a triceratops they haven't
given us anything to work off of yes but
we need them they protect us silent
protectors that boat is badass
it keeps getting better
Oh on to the next don't see more give me
more
judgment the official extended TV spot
number-one judgment I'm so excited you
don't even know
go back madam I love how they kept the
bumblebee in it
yeah every time I every time I see that
one I keep thinking Davy Jones come
pirate cool
family freakin Gucci max I am so psyched
first off Marky Mark stanley tucci both
greats put them together I know there's
a triceratops not just that but also
Triceratops and iams oh it's sad because
I know there's gonna be more dirt is
always more and the cool thing that I
like about the trailers that they do for
transformers is they never give you they
never overload you you always know
there's gonna be more they always lead
up to something but they always leave
the best for the movie itself so when
you go see it you're just overloaded of
awesome don't know what to do with
yourself in a an awesome coma and that's
what I look forward to every time I go
to these movies it's just it's so true
to the Transformers series and I'm not
just saying that because I really buy it
but honestly I love transformers and I
loved what Michael Bay did with the
series kind of revamped it into more
badassery in my opinion yes I know it's
you know lots of explosions everywhere
and that's like the thing that he does
but it works it works with transformers
cuz you know things blow up everywhere
anyway so white as well do it right
right right so that's all I got for you
keep watching cuz I'm sure there's gonna
be lots more different stuff coming up
cuz this year's like your of the movies
of all the awesome movies I'm looking
forward to this year it keeps getting
better and better and better and better
so well that that's dealio up there you
should click that cuz we love you I love
you we all do that would be amazing you
know I have a channel too so if you like
me I hope you do this one right here
that one you should click that and do it
goes device personal channel
yeah and I'm also you know I'm gonna say
this because everyone overlooks this and
it's underrated but facebook facebook
page i have one i think the real rejects
has one so like the one facebook like me
on facebook facebook it up
time cuz we love the shoutouts here at
real rejects k my first shoutout is
gonna be to Charlie Brown
because Charlie Brown is amazing and
decided that he wanted to make an
animated intro for my channel and I'm
super appreciative of that right now so
that's my personal little shout-out
thank you so much Charlie Brown Marcus
Smith 49 lol I love you guys
everyone on this channel is brilliant
but I think I just completely fell in
love with ELISA after this and ELISA
Fool's Day video she's beautiful down to
earth a great actress and has a great
sense of humor and is in video games
such a perfect girl could I possibly get
a shout-out from her please that made me
smile oh my and to be completely honest
you were the first one to ask for a
shout-out from me sabe be really really
really happy thank you and Eric's
Slusher she's awesome
can I get a shoutout yeah you can have a
shout-out why can't you get a shout-out
here's your shoutout I love you guys
yeah